so just have a look with me down here in
this little quadrant diagram the
quadrant diagram is enormously useful
but it has a few blind spots you might
have noticed that if you pay super close
attention to my inequalities I didn't
draw our attention to it so maybe didn't
notice you've got acute angles down here
right so that's between naught and pi on
two and then you transition from acute
angles to talking about obtuse angles so
these are from PI onto up to PI right so
acute less than PI on two obtuse bigger
than PI onto but we never in this
diagram talk about what happens in
between
right when an angle is neither a cute
nor obtuse you have 90 degrees PI on two
that's a right angle yeah
now all of the right angles here PI on
two pi 3 PI on two and you can think of
this as zero or as two pi
they become problematic for us because
you can't fit them in right angle
triangle so you can't fit piyo too but
then you're like which one's the
adjacent side like is it this one or is
it this one it's a bit confusing right
so that's why we kind of need to break
out of just right angle triangles and
think about this guy the unit circle now
hopefully this rings a bit of a bell but
some of you are going to feel like this
is the first time so I'm gonna walk you
through it okay if this is the unit
circle again we mentioned this this
morning the whole unit of unit circle
refers to one unit being the radius of
this circle so here's the radius here
from the origin out to the circumference
okay
now if you think about this point up
here and this point up here on the
circumference right if we think about
its x and y coordinates you can work
them out like if I said oh that's three
comma four it's not because this is the
unit circle but if it were what I mean
is go to the right three units and up
four units right so if I can work out
how far across I am and how high are by
oh I can work out what x and y are okay
so if I give this angle a name let's
just call it theta right I can use just
my regular right angle triangle trig to
work out what these lengths are for
instance see this horizontal one here
which is X what's the ratio that links
the adjacent side adjacent with the
hypotenuse adjacent over hypotenuse
that's cos right cos theta in this
particular triangle equals adjacent over
hypotenuse which is have a look
x over 1 which is X that's just it so I
could say x equals cos theta what about
this vertical length why haven't you met
this guy what's the ratio or the yeah
it's gonna be opposite on hypotenuse
which is sine right
so sine of theta equals y over 1 which
is why like you said so what we're
saying here is that the X or the Y
coordinates you can state them in terms
of the angle you can call this cos theta
sine theta right instead of thinking
about x and y you can just have it in
terms of your angle right now reason why
this is valuable is a whole bunch of
reasons but particularly for us it
cracks these weird right angle
businesses right let's try PI on to
where would PI on to if I spun up plan
to where would that leave me on the
circumference what AG that'd be where I
am you start from here start from the
positive horizontal and then you spin up
your right angle your PI on to and then
there's where you are okay can you tell
me what are the x and y coordinates of
that spot the x coordinate I have got
anywhere horizontally so it's 0 what
about the y coordinate it's the unit
circle remember it's one thank you very
much so what this is telling you is for
this particular this is PI or two right
cos of Pi on 2 is 0 and sine of pi/2 is
1 and you can check this on your
calculator right but we can keep going
round what angle would get me to here to
this spot think about the angle I've got
to rotate all the way around here what
angles that that's PI right just just a
straight angle so once I get to PI
what are the coordinates of this spot
it's the unit circle right one so
whatever you do
yeah it's negative one have come to the
left so it's negative one that's the
horizontal and then how far up a denim I
know we're at zero so remember you told
me that that was pi radians so cos of Pi
will be negative one that's what that
means in fact I could write these
coordinates as cos pi sine pi go ahead
and Chuck into your calculator sign of
pilots should if you've got in the right
mode heads back zero down the bottom
this can play going around right what
are the coordinates at that point figure
out it zero negative one what's the
angle that goes with this point it's not
pi on - it's not pi it's three PI on two
it's got all the way around right so in
other words cause of three pi on two is
zero and sine of three PI on two is
negative one and you can check this all
on your calculator right the last one is
this guy
you can I think if this is 0 or is 2 pi
I've gone all the way around can you go
ahead and tell me the coordinates the
coordinates coordinates 1 comma 0 cos of
0 is 1 its sine of 0 is 0 so these are
what we call the unit circle definitions
of cosine and sine in fact I can think
about this without any of this triangle
involved I just got that there to help
us work out the coordinates but then you
saw I just kept on going around around
the circle no triangles inside when you
get to a question like this cos x equals
negative 1 I can't remember which one
this is Jemaine but that was when we
looked at cos x equals negative 1
I'll make it theta because the x and y
is a bit confusing cos of theta equals
negative 1
where is it 7j a thank you
I'm looking for is cause the the X
corner or the y coordinate have a look
it's the X corner right so which of
these points has an x coordinate of
negative 1 how long where is it where
would you describe it it's isn't it this
guy there's the X quart x coordinate of
negative 1 right so what's the angle
that goes with that and the answer is
it's pi right so your solution to this
guy is just that within the normal
domain ok now this is a bit of a mind
shift take some getting used to so I'm
gonna pause now you've got all of that
up on the board I encourage you to I
didn't bring the rest of the pairs of
coppers with me sorry mrs. Lee's has a
few not as many as we had this morning
but if you can't draw a circle neatly
then ask us it's better to have a good
circle on your page and then go ahead
and draw this diagram make it nice and
big ok you'll made up for this tricky
ones